um in Asia congratulations we're waiting
for y'all to come back so we can turn up
at drays tonight 40 in the bill
in the building about the crowd in the
finals we talked about the crowd but now
I got to talk to you about the crowd in
this parade later this week tell Vegas
how they should come into this parade
and the energy level
you have to take my shots children take
shot in Darrell but you got to take four
shots before you pull up to the parade
and drink responsibly but in order to
get to the parade you got to be four
shots in it's unacceptable of you not
the the Bellagio Fountains we skiing
across that thing we going crazy because
like I don't think people understand how
important this really is this is huge so
Vegas turn up I saw the cops with our
logo on the car y'all better laced up
cause we about to go crazy so
Tuesday 5 30 p.m Pacific Time be there
be square if you ain't if you ain't four
shots in don't come stay at the house
children drink some ginger ale pop
ginger ale drink responsibly don't be
crazy now but Usher I better see you
Usher I'm not playing with you
everybody come to the city he's trying
to do this Usher's not on Zoom yet so
we're going to finish with me